whenever our body is attacked by a
pathogen such as an bacteria the first
line of defense is the Anette immune
system in it immune system components
such as macrophages dendritic cells
attack these pathogens and try to
neutralize them apart from macrophage
and dendritic system one other component
which is secreted in the bloodstream are
the complement proteins this complement
proteins can also mount an immune
response against this pathogen and try
to neutralize these pathogens or help
the other components of the innate
immune system such as macrophages to
engulf the pathogens in this video we
would talk about these complement
proteins and their mode of action so
complement proteins basically help in
opsonization opsonization is equivalent
to the term neutralization by
opsonization this complement protein
creates a coat of coat around the
pathogen which is recognized by several
phagocytosis cell such as macrophages
apart from that these complement protein
once activated can create membrane pore
from this membrane pore fluid can leak
out as a result it can create osmolarity
disbalance
and thereby lysis of the bacteria apart
from that some of these complement
system proteins are potent and aflatoxin
enough flow toxins at those proteins
which has huge role in inflammation we
would see all of these function one by
one in this video now complement
proteins are produced by the liver and
they are circulated into the bloodstream
the complement proteins even though are
circulated by in the bloodstream they
don't harm caused harm to the body
because they are in an inactive state
and they need proteolytic cleavage in
order to get activated and we would see
how selective pathogen encounter can
allow them to be activated and does and
thereby performing the downstream action
now complement pathways are divided or
subdivided into three categories one
category is known as classical pathway
in the classical pathway the epitopes or
the antigens on top of our bacteria is
recognized by antibodies and these
antibodies are conjugated with several
complement proteins such as C 1 Q C 1 s
and C 1 are complex and thereby it
activates membrane pore formation or
optimization of the pathogen apart from
that several pathogen associated
molecular pattern more selectively
specific oligosaccharide residues on the
bacteria could be selectively detected
by the mannose binding lectin and also
that leads to complement cascade and
thereby activation of the membrane
attack complex and lysis of the bacteria
once another pathway is alternative
pathway alternative pathway involves
factor B and factor D which is also
converging like the other pathways in
forming a membrane pool or oxidizing the
bacteria so we will look at the
classical pathway in this video B the
classical pathway B the other pathway
the steps of these compliment as a
compliment mediated response is very
similar
first step is initiation after
recognizing this specific pathogen
either the that is recognized by c1 Q or
it is recognized by M BL or it is
recognized by Phil Cohen so this
initiation step leads to activation of
several complement proteins and these
complement proteins form convert is
complex
this convert is complex can actually
form a lot of proteolytic cleavage and
it can activate other complement
proteins and they ultimately help in
forming the membrane attack complex and
also many of these complement proteins
which are activated by the converters
complex are decorating the surface of
the bacteria which would be recognized
by several phases to excel such as
macrophages and it would be engulfed now
we go to the details of the complement
path the classical complement pathway
classical component complement pathway
begins with the recognition of specific
antigen epitopes on the bacterial cell
surface by antibodies and these
antibodies are further recognized by the
c1 complex the c1 complement protein
complex involves c1 q which is a multi
mer having coiled-coil domains and c1 R
and C 1 s both of which are protease is
once bound to the antibodies this c1 R
and C 1 s change its conformation and
its proteolytic activity is getting
initiated
now once c1 R and C 1s are activated
they can cleave complement protein c4 to
give rise to C for P and C for a now see
for a is opponent enough low toxin also
c2 can be converted to C 2 P and C 2 a
this C 2 B and C 4 B together form the
c3 convertase this c3 convertase
is very important because it can
activate many other complement cascade
pathways c3 convertase most importantly
cleave c3 and form c 3 b and c 3 a again
c 3 a is NN aflatoxin and we will look
at what this enough low toxin are doing
however C 2 B and so this enough low
toxin C to a CF or a or C 3 a all of
these
can attract macrophages from the blood
system so it would allow extravasation
of the leukocytes such that macrophages
and many other pathogen recognition
cells can attack the pathogen
so these C 3 B C to a and C 4 B these
three components make a c5 convertase
just like acid free convertase again the
function of these convert is is to
activate many other complement protein
one such is C 3 B and C 3 B itself is
recognized by specific receptor on the
macrophages as a result what happens
macrophage can engulf it apart from that
it can activate C 5 and C 5 a is cleaved
and c3b c1q all of these are going to be
recognized by macrophages by specific
receptors and thereby macrophage can
engulf the opsin eyes pathogen however
this whole c5 convertase activates many
other complement system proteins such as
c5 p c6 c7 c8 and ultimately this huge
complex allow the formation of c9
membrane attack complex the c9 membrane
attack complex is nothing but a pore on
the bacterial membrane the c9 attack
complex and c9 attack complex can allow
water to come out from the bacterial
cell causing her osmotic disbalance and
thereby bursting of the bacteria and
thereby neutralizing the threat this is
how we looked at how classical
complement pathway can work and how
specific complement pathway proteins are
orchestrating this response by
coordinating with each other and the
overall response is either opsonization
thereby involving the pathogen by the
macrophages or forming the membrane
attack complex and thereby also
Lauretta disbalance and thereby bursting
of the pathogen is the outcome of the
complement pathway so if you liked this
video give it a big thumbs up don't
forget to Like share and subscribe and
also in next few videos I will be
talking about the MBL pathway the
letting dependent pathway and the
alternative pathway so stay tuned for
that thank you